hello this video is for the people that
are having
trouble getting obs working on linux
specifically
opensuse 15.2
because that's what i'm using here and
that's what i've been uh figuring out so
as you can see i have it running and
recording as of right now but it took me
a while to get this sorted out and i'll
just show you basically what all i had
to do
because it wasn't easy it wasn't
straightforward
there was a few hints on forums about
what to do
but definitely nothing that spelled it
out directly
so it's probably going to be kind of
long because i'm going to try to explain
everything i've ran into
sure i'll miss something but hopefully
this helps someone
so i'll cut to the chase and i'll try to
get the quick version done first and
then i'll explain more afterwards
okay so i did eventually find this post
that
led me to the solution and you can see
it all here
basically yeah you when you click start
recording
well i don't get nothing happens i get
i had a thing where it said it couldn't
start recording
check your nvec or something which i'm
not using and
i'm having nvidia card i'm not using in
invec um see it's
in the e and c
i i don't think it's pronounced in fact
this whole thing so you can get this
working on linux but it's not provided
you have to
compile it yourself you basically have
to compile all this yourself and then
compile obs with support for and compile
ffmpeg with it
i might do that in a later video but
this it all started with me trying to
figure out this that's why i'm
mentioning that okay
so there i got was
your invec might not be properly
supported but
i know i'm jumping around a little bit
you guys just gonna have to deal this
was really confused
figure it out so uh
all right so i checked the logs the logs
gave me
a hint and you can check your logs by
going to your files
and control h to show your hidden files
or however you need to show your hidden
files and look
big run a different os it might be in a
different spot
here we have obs studio and then we have
blocks and in the latest log here
it's probably fine
let's see uh
yeah no errors see we got the ffmp
coder but like if i look at one of these
previous logs where i was having the
error
okay that one doesn't have it does this
one
oh let's check this one this one
definitely had it
okay well
here we go here's one that had it all
right
i guess i tried it a bunch of times
while i was working or something but at
the very bottom it says
ffmpeg aac encoder track one couldn't
find encoder
which you know doesn't really make sense
because if you go to your terminal and
follow the advice
of people online what you get
so you do this ffmpeg codex grep aac
so you see only the lines that have aac
and basically what you see is
that you do have it you indeed have aac
so it should work but it doesn't
all right so
do that all right well what you do next
is
uh okay here's what i did there might be
other ways to do this
basically go to your control center your
software management
and okay uh this is where opensuse is
kind of broken
so i just kept running into broken
things
it was kind of frustrating but
eventually i figured it out
so uh you basically have to use the
pacman repos
good luck with that it doesn't work
because i don't know they haven't
updated it or something or it's just a
little broken there's a lot of annoying
little broken things
like get to the bottom someone says
solved
and basically you have to
okay so the issue and this is the
correct issue you install obs
from the pacman repo or the home repo
it will fail to encode if you already
had the ffmpeg installed from the
default
opensuse repo
which it shouldn't because as you see
aac is on there there's no reason it
shouldn't work
but it doesn't and that's the reason
it's some wrong version it's
i i don't know i do not know the answer
to why it's not using
anything that's ready but
you do have to remove this default
version
of ffmpeg that comes with suse
and you have to use the one from the
pacman repo
now that also doesn't work see
uh problem all starts
when you go to uh repositories
and you want to install pacman one right
okay i had to do this manually
so that one i added manually because
normally what you do is you just go
add community repos
next gets you a list
and you choose the pacman one but but
thank you opensuse developers for
missing this
sarcastic it's please fix this
you add it and it fails because i don't
know
they because i wasn't consulted when
they compiled and released
this version that's that's why it's
broken
so you have to go online and find the
actual link
to this because the one that's within
the os
they overlooked that
so that's the first step you'll run into
that snag if you're following guides
they always tell you to do it this way
and normally that works
but it doesn't in this case so yet
another annoying snag
based on developers overlooking things
who would have thought i know you're
busy but
come on you're making it extra hard by
leaving this broken stuff in
all right so once you get the pacman
repo added you saw the address in there
of it if you
can't find it on do a search you'll
probably be able to find it
then what you can do is you can search
ffmpeg
i am on view here just the default one
uh i think it's just on search yeah
so you do a search and you find it but
you don't see any different
ones mainly all you want is this one
right here this top one
so there's multiple of these so you have
to go down the tabs here
go to versions yes versions
and you'll notice that the one that's
checked is probably this one from
opensuseleap.2
so if you have this one checked or yeah
if you have that this one checked
obs won't work so what you have to do is
you have to check
the other one instead which is uh this
one up here
then you have to hit accept and it's
going to tell you you need to replace
all the
old libraries so just do it it's option
number one
i'm not going to do it again because i
already did it and it'll just be
confusing
i guess i could show you an example of
what it looks like by selecting this old
one again
but the one you want is this one from
pacman
you'll get this sort of prompt you'll
get this warning and you just have to
say
you have to do number one which
uninstalls the old version
let's send a new one
but i'm not going to do this because i
already already went through all this
uninstalling the opensuse a1
installing the pacman that makes sense
uh just to be clear you can't have them
both so
it knows that at least all right well
once you do that
you can just launch obs as usual
i'm going to make any changes there
there and it'll finally start recording
so hopefully that helps
that's totally stuck uh
this is well they got they definitely
got the problem right
but uh oh this is kind of an old post
it's going on two and a half years old
so that's that's part of it but yeah
based on it having the proper output it
should work and i guess people said that
up here too
they're like yeah as it still
still doesn't work so thank you
this guy dominic
this was the first solution i found
after
searching for a long time and yeah after
applying all those workarounds
it seemed to work let me know if you
have any questions down below
hopefully this works uh you all right
so other things yeah
you only get the software encoder which
is x264
and uh you can get the nvac encoder if
you haven't video card like i said if
you do all that compiling
i might make a video on that later i'm
not sure i'd like to get it working and
if i do
all right well that's going to do it i
can't really think of anything else to
add
because if i do i feel like i'll just
make this more but uh
yeah that's going to do it all right
peace out guys welcome to linux week on
my channel
don't forget to hit all the buttons see
you next time